Ось такі тепер звуки природи на березі річки Боржава, що на Закарпатті.
Так на сонці тріскається, розширюючись, пластик.
Він створив найбільший затор на річці та повністю перекрив рух води.
Плаває тут навіть холодильник,
тож, схоже,  сміття залишили не туристи, а місцеві жителі.
В селах є централізоване сміттєвивезення. Тобто проблема знаходиться вище.
Це Виноградівський район та інша гірська місцевість.
Там, де немає централізованого вивезення через нерентабельність.
Боржава - притока річки Тиси, а Тиса бере свій початок у верхів'ї українських Карпат
та тече до сусідніх Румунії та Угорщини, тож щороку після повені на Закарпатті
тисячі тонн пластику, скла та інших відходів річка несе до Євросоюзу.
Це стає причиною міжнародних сміттєвих скандалів
Не виняток і цей рік. Після Закарпатської повені
угорський президент вчергове адресував лідерам двох країн - України і Румунії - ноти протесту.
Ситуацію зі сміттям в Україні він назвав критичною
та "не гідною європейських стандартів". Нарікав і на те, що
угорська техніка вже не в змозі впоратися з купами українського сміття.
Це вже друга нота протесту нинішньому керівництву України від Угорщини.
Втім, якщо рік тому новообраному  президенту
було не до закарпатського сміття, то цього року під тиском ЄС
Зеленський проблему побачив і доручив очільнику області її вирішити.
Цьому в першу чергу радіють селищні голови,
для яких сміттєвий колапс - постійний привід для суперечок.
- Сперечаємось за то, хто посилає мені бутилки сюди.
- То не ми посилаємо. Василь Миколайович знає, що то не ми.
У нас є централізований вивіз. Можливо, одиниці,
я не хочу казати, що ніхто не вивозить на річку... то ексклюзивні випадки.
Але більшість сміття йде з Іршавського, Виноградівського району і Свалявського.
Сільські голови  згадують, що востаннє річка чистилась у 2012 році,.
та й те - коштом Європейського Союзу. Відтоді про сміттєву проблему в області не згадували.
Якщо Берегівський район,  рівнинний, і більш-менш на непоганому рівні організований,
то гірські райони Закарпаття - це проблеми.
Комплексна проблема, не можна сказати, що тільки сільських голів, селищних...
Це проблема людей і влади.
Самотужки тут упоратися зі сміттям не можуть.
Кажуть, що не мають ані відповідного обладнання, ані людського ресурсу.
Завдяки голові ОДА, що він це зачав, і це питання підняв. Я йому дякую.
Вітання DW передає  очільнику області Олексію Петрову особисто.
Він передає привіт, і я йому теж передаю привіт..
От зараз це відповідальність органів місцевого самоврядування.
У них є бюджет, вони його перерозподіляють.
Вони мають впливати на свідомість і на культуру своїх громадян в громаді.
Водночас і в обласному центрі кажуть: без Києва проблему сміття в регіоні не вирішити.
Зокрема, чекають на остаточне ухвалення закону про управління відходами.
Його завдяки тому ж таки міжнародному тиску нарешті ухвалили
у першому читанні депутати Верховної Ради. Згідно з проєктом закону,
має запрацювати принцип "забруднювач платить".
Тобто виробники пластикових пляшок, батарейок, скла будуть нести відповідальність
за утилізацію свого виробу. Крім того, в законі мають прописати
шляхи залучення інвестицій для будівництва сміттєпереробних заводів.
Наприклад, за рахунок фонду, який поповнюватиметься
коштами виробників упаковок. Це дасть поштовх
для переговорів з потенційними інвесторами заводів.
Поки ми на ці закони очікуємо, коли їх приймуть,
коли будуть механізми. Ми боремося з командою однодумців
за вторсировину і органіку, щоб створити завод по компостуванню
- це полігон по компостуванню -  і створити сміттєсортування,
щоб ці пляшки, скло і пластик теж не залишилась, а йшли на переробку.
Шанси не доводити ситуацію до критичного стану в області були,
каже місцева екологиня Оксана Станкевич-Волосянчук.
Адже у 2012 році на Закарпатті була розроблена єдина в Україні
регіональна Стратегія поводження з відходами. В ній по пунктах вказано, що робити,
аби протягом 15 років вирішити сміттєву проблему. Втім,
до сьогодні жоден з пунктів не виконаний.
Все це мало працювати вже досить довгий час, але жодна з адміністрацій нічого не зробила,
аби ця стратегія запрацювала, і сьогодні я знову чую про розробку якогось документу,
і я вже заплуталась, про що саме йдеться.
Знову йдеться про роробку стратегії і якогось плану дій.
Тобто наразі я не зовсім розумію, як всі ці документи узгоджуються один з одним,
і я особливо не бачу ніяких конкретних кроків.
Єдине зрушення -  це  будівництво за кошти Угорщини сміттєпереробного заводу.
Втім, рік тому через через стрибок курсу валюти його так і не відкрили.
Та навіть аби завод працював, слід запровадити роздільний збір відходів серед населення.
Не всі селяни звикли до того, що за таку послугу треба платити.
Кожен тиждень приходить машина і забирає сміття. Доволі дорого.
Це 98 грн. в місяць, на наші зарплати -  дорого.
Але куди діватись. Ліпше, ніж раніше було. Раніше не було куди покласти.
Сортували, аби були б баки, або аби сказали, що приїжджають в понеділок
по одне сміття, а вівторок - по друге. А так все, що є, складаємо в один бак.
Яношівський сортувальний завод... уже би його було потрібно закінчити.
Ми були проти цього сортувального заводу, але якщо він уже побудований,
то треба запустити, аби вже працював.
Може б, він дійсно сортував наше сміття а так, поки все скидається в один бак.
Найбільше п'ють пива. Оце все - з-під пива.
Коричневий ПЕТ.
Оце скільки банок залізних. Подивіться, скільки одягу, взуття різного розміру.
Це вони скидають в річку.
Віктор Бучинський сміттям почав займатись рік тому,
коли після відпочинку на річці вперше побачив подібні пластикові затори
і вже не зміг залишитись осторонь сміттєвого лиха.
Він відкрив у Береговому сортувальну станцію "Кольорові баки" та популяризує
серед людей здорове споживання. Втім, поки забруднювачів довкілля в рази більше.
Його станція не самоокупна, а на заклики прибрати річку Боржаву
приходять лише  кілька осіб.
І все ж активіст наразі рук не опускає. Натомість розмірковує,
чи не варто піти в місцеву політику, аби надати необхідних імпульсів для змін у владі.